one of the great challenges in medicine
especially in the modern era is the
healthcare leader is trying to balance
big data cutting-edge research with a
fundamental sense of caring for the
patient how do you deliver the sense of
care in caring while still delivering
cutting-edge science
I knew that anything that involved
Stanford GSB the Design School was gonna
be something that was really gonna
challenge your mind in a new way not
your typical leadership program and then
when I saw that I had the
interdisciplinary work with the medical
school I felt like it was my life
wrapped up in a program the innovative
healthcare leader program is a new
offering here at Stanford University
that's offered jointly between the
School of Medicine and the Graduate
School of Business
the innovative healthcare leader is
tremendously exciting for me because
we're really capturing a synergy that is
everything that Stanford's about Abraham
said something one of his lectures that
has stuck with me which was that the
Stone Age didn't end because we ran out
of stones and as I'm thinking about
things changing in medicine it's not
that the things we have aren't working
it's just new things keep coming one of
the goals of the 21st century leader is
to remove the impediments to creativity
remove the impediments to innovation and
this course is really about
understanding what elements in your
culture or perhaps even in your own
personality or in your workplace or
actually preventing you from allowing
innovation to happen one of the great
strengths of the Graduate School of
Business is the way that they've
championed design thinking the d.school
is unique that was one of the wonderful
parts of this program it helped strip us
down a little bit the team approach
coming together with people that you
didn't know and through the process of
working together here we challenged each
other and came up with different ways of
thinking of a problem because I'm
thinking methodology allows us to break
big problems down into small manageable
chunks and then innovate to develop
solutions for those problems in a way
that feels much less overwhelming
were on the edge of this destructive
industry and it's really helpful to step
back from that a bit and focus on
strategies to be even more effective in
that role I'm leading a program that has
grown dramatically over the past two
years I really hadn't thought about some
of the challenges that even would come
up in that process and I feel like I'm
going back with some tools to better
manage that change now and to help my
team better be a part of that process
bit of compass resetting is an important
part of the week here so at the same
time that it does represent an
investment in time the return on that
investment is the chance to rethink the
direction that you're moving in in your
institution or in one's hospital or
workplace the healthcare leader of the
future has to worry about the patient
but also about the welfare of the people
taking care of them nothing else is
going to work if your work forces on
having this intersection of some of the
best minds in medicine and some of the
best minds in business will offer health
care leaders tools for leadership and
innovation to manage change in this ever
changing healthcare environment how do
we keep that art in medicine how do we
keep that patient contact in spite of
all this technology and things that are
being pulled from us I think there's a
gap between our intent and the actual
execution between the wonderful
technology we have and the fundamental
senses Peabody said many many years ago
that the secret of the care of the
patient is in caring for the patient
you